[Applaudissements]
mais je vous dis qu'il nous reste que 24
heures mais vous me prenez porter ça
fait des mois que je me bats pour ça on
n'arrivera pas ben non mais je suis
désolé moi j'ai un objectif à remplir
je vous laisse vous avez vu ça fabrice
des touristes sont restés bloqués
pendant 16 heures dans un aéroport avec
cauet hockey l'horreur wes et non 16
heures non qu en mai mais il ya pire
je connais des gens qui sont bloqués
depuis quatre ans sur un plateau avec
hanouna fabrice sinon s combien de temps
il nous reste 24 heures chrono comme
dirait jack bauer et comme dit axel
bauer cargo de nuit 35 jours sans voir
la mer c'est quoi le rapport d'artaud
encore en maison même nom de famille
j'aime bien la chanson bon 24 24 heures
vous n'avez jamais y arriver bertrand 24
heures c'est impossible donc aussi un
riff fabrice il ya un prime de demain
et alors rendez vous demain
qu'est-ce que vous fabriquez s'en aller
c'est bon c'est fini maintenant il reste
plus que deux épisodes rideau on ferme
la boutique terminé à l'année prochaine
mais aux fins soyez pas défaitiste comme
ça à mon petit vous avez écouté série
d'annulations rampant ce matin prénom on
arrive à les voir du ménage on a vu
draps banc de touche pas à mon poste on
a vu que vous étiez en train de faire
pas mal de casting de voir beaucoup de
gens on va commencer par le début vous
verrez qui je vire personnes personne
personne et direct je vous jure
personnes des virées bas-normands
bertrand et il dit que personne va être
viré
oui mais parlez pas encore le hanouna
souvenez vous ce qu'il disait ya deux
semaines à propos des licenciements je
crois que je n'ai jamais virer quelqu'un
dans une froide sous les roues les gars
sont partis d'eux-mêmes ou bien sourire
l'usé jamais rappelé away we will
avantage avec à nous menacer qui nous
aura fait rire jusqu'au bout donc il va
virer des gens donc à une opportunité de
prendre une place mais s'ils jouent et
franc avec vous fabrice j'ai pris ma
décision concernant mon avenir
télévisuel
fabrice je me devais de vous l'annoncer
mais aussi aux personnes qui nous
regarde en ce moment même
j'ai décidé de fabrice
c'est un plaisir de travailler avec vous
tous tendre cette année mais force est
de constater que ce soir c'est la
dernière de la saison pour touche pas à
mon poste est sans doute ma dernière
également puisque j'ai failli à ma
mission je n'ai pas atteint l'objectif
que je m'étais fixé devenir pas qui à la
place du pâquis il m'a mis des bâtons
dans les roues
il a été omniprésent dans les médias
cette année il a sorti un album il était
invité dans quarante huit émissions
il a présenté touche pas à mon poste
l'oeuf ou la poule les pieds dans le
plat sur europe 1 le gros show the cover
[Rires]
qu'elle met toujours est t'il fabrice
que je tire les conséquences de cet
échec
et j'annonce mon retrait de la vie
médiatique à compter de ce soir c'est
fini pour moi toutes ces conneries tant
pis pour le 7 d'or fabrice me bertrand
vous allez faire quoi
je sais pas j'ai une foire à la saucisse
sur le parking d'intermarché près de
nice demain
ou peut-être les ch'tis à marseille
[Musique]
monsieur
vous avez vu la demande il y c'est la
nouvelle n'est pas là ce soir là tout
cas de trop il ya passé la journée
cloué au chiotte faites ce que vous
voulez de cette information
tu l'avais pas vu venir celle là eh
ouais bienvenue dans le paf
parce que l'année prochaine ça sera le
journal de fabrice comme dit guy lux à
la télé il faut toujours surveiller ses
arrières
[Rires]
oui bah c'est bon ils sont neutralisés